writers and actors are striking in sunny
California and a movie studio just so
happened to trim the city's trees that
were providing shade to the protesters
you know what that means it finally
happened
we're talking tree law baby
finally happened yay all right so the
city of Los Angeles has fined NBC
Universal 250 after the company trimmed
ficus trees that striking writers and
actors were using for shade while
picketing at the Universal Studios lot
was this a deliberate attempt to hurt
the strikers during an unprecedented
heat wave as the mayor and Strikers
alleged and if so then why is universal
only getting a slap on the wrist or was
it just a simple misunderstanding and
coincidence well welcome to the wild
world of tree law now on July 17th Ryder
and sag member Chris Stevens shared a
photo of a row of ficus trees outside of
the Universal Studios lot in Los Angeles
quote quick shout out to the good people
at Universal picks for trimming the
trees that gave our picket line shade
right before 90 plus degree week it
appeared that the trees had their
branches and leaves trimmed down over
the weekend when Strikers showed up for
the picket line on Monday they found
that their shade was gone and in the
photo you can see the before and after
that Stevens referred to Stevens and the
other Strikers suggested that the tree
trimming was a pretext to take shade
from striking sag after workers the
Union's 160 000 members went on strike
in July along with the 11 000 Riders
Guild of America members who have been
on strike since May now in most cities
you can't just trim or remove trees
without a permit as most people on the
Internet seem to know in Los Angeles
these trees are along a sidewalk that is
considered public property their
maintenance is under the jurisdiction of
the urban forestry division of the
Bureau of street services the urban
forestry division manages nearly 700 000
Street trees growing along 6500 miles of
public roads making the city of Los
Angeles Street tree population the
largest urban forest in the nation and
possibly the world and streets La has a
website where you can actually look up
all 700 000 trees in the city and when I
type in 3801 Barnum Boulevard into the
search site it pulls up those that line
the streets that are in question here
and since so many people have a passion
for tree law yes ICU 78 000 members of
reddit's tree law Forum a let me do a
quick rundown on this apparently
intoxicating legal specialty in the
United States state and local
governments have jurisdiction over tree
laws tree law governs issues like who
owns trees how neighbors handle tree
disputes whether tree is on government
property when trees become hazardous and
whether a person can cut down trees on
their own property now generally if your
neighbor's tree branches or Roots cross
onto your property you can cut them down
if they're creating a hazard however if
you damage your neighbor's tree in the
process you might have to pay for the
damage now tree law is a very thorny
issue but if you need to Branch out and
get a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've been in a car
crash suffered a data breach or have
social security disability issues we can
represent you or help find you the right
attorney who can just click on the link
in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is below now Los
Angeles has special rules for protected
trees covering mostly oak trees that are
indigenous to California illegal pruning
or willful damage to protected oak trees
can result in a ten thousand dollar fine
and and or six months in jail this city
also protects Heritage trees which are
quote individual trees of any size or
species that are specifically designated
as a Heritage because of their
historical commemorative or
Horticultural significance there are
Steve fines for damaging trees with
historical significance like the tuna
Canyon detention stations to hunga Oak
Grove these trees are The Last Remnant
of a World War II era Japanese detention
Camp The Ficus trees outside of
Universal Studios lot located at 3801
Barnum Boulevard are not protected or
historical instead they are considered
quote a Parkway tree a Parkway tree is a
tree that is planted by public works or
the developer who built the building
adjacent to the edge of the roadway now
for Parkway trees the city follows the
recommendations of the international
Society of Arbor culture which generally
recommends that most trees be trimmed
during the dormant season the dormant
season for ficus trees is fall or winter
arborists were also concerned about the
way the universal trees were trimmed
because they appear to have been topped
now topping is the removal of the top of
the central stem of a tree call the
leader as well as the upper main
branches now Los Angeles has formally
adopted the American National Standard
institute's pruning standards the NC
says quote topping in Lions tailing
shall be considered unacceptable pruning
practices for trees Universal told
deadline and quote prune these trees
annually at this time of the year though
one Constantine Anthony a member of sag
after questioned whether this was true
we can't find any work orders done for
this particular tree trimming which is
problematic in Southern California we
have a lot of laws governing trees
normally you don't trim until October
um and in fact the exact same style and
type of tree about 200 feet this way are
not trimmed but those aren't providing
shade to the picketers are they LA City
controller Kenneth Mejia investigative
matter and said his office hadn't given
Universal a tree trimming permit in
three years he concluded that Universal
should have gotten a permit and Mejia
fined NBC Universal 250 because that is
the maximum penalty allowed for a
first-time offender he tweeted that
quote streets La finds all first-time
offenders regardless of the number of
trees at issue a 250 penalty if
violations continue the fines can grow
to one thousand dollars if trees are
found to be significantly damaged La can
require the offenders to plant two trees
per damaged tree now I should note as a
long time former resident of Los Angeles
I've seen these kinds of trees all over
the city of La and often pruned in this
manner I have no idea whether people are
getting permits for this kind of thing
but it also seems like a lot of people
tend to prune these kinds of trees in
the summertime so at least from that
aspect anecdotally in my own personal
experience it doesn't seem that out of
character
and in this case streets La determined
that the trees didn't suffer significant
damage and would easily recover in 6 to
12 months but he had pointed out that
LA's 12 tree inspectors have the
impossible job of monitoring over 700
000 trees and he said the system isn't
working as intended and as much as I'd
love to demonize the movie studios here
another issue with these kinds of trees
is that they grow so fast that they
often tend to interfere with traffic so
it wouldn't be surprising if one wanted
to err on the side of trimming the trees
rather than letting them grow wild which
literally can impact the cars that are
driving by but the city's fine here
isn't the end of the story between the
unions and Universal both sag Astra and
the wga filed formal unfair Labor
practice charges against Universal an
unfair label practice referred to as a
ulp is an action by an employer or a
union that violates the National Labor
Relations Act and the nlra was passed in
1935 its aim is to encourage collective
bargaining between workers and employers
and the nlra gives employees the
fundamental right to seek better working
conditions is without fear of
retaliations now classic examples of ulp
by an employer include firing or
penalizing employees who exercise any of
the rights under the nlra including the
right to pick it an employer as those
striking actors and writers were doing
outside of the universe a lot and the
SAG after charge says quote Universal
was interfering with lawful picketing
activity by designating as picketing
locations areas where the public
sidewalks have been covered up with
construction fencing forcing picketers
to patrol in busy streets with
significant car traffic where two
Pickers have already been struck by a
car and by refusing to provide k-rail
barriers to establish pedestrian
walkways for picketers to use after Los
Angeles Police Department advised the
employer weeks ago in the interest of
Public Safety to do so the union said
that this was suspiciously timed
construction and that the loss of tree
shade during a record Heat Wave has
forced sag-aftra to determine that it
cannot safely send its members to
Pickett at NBC Universal now Universal
said it regretted that its decision
created unintended challenges for
demonstrators that was not Our intention
in partnership with licensed arborist we
have pruned those trees annually at this
time of the year to ensure that the
canopies are light ahead of the high
wind this season now it's certainly
possible that this was simply a
coincidence and not a ulp we just don't
know but it's also important to look at
why the unions are striking in the first
place because for the first time since
Ronald Reagan was the union boss yes
that is actually a thing that happened
the unions representing actors and
writers are staging a strike at the same
time the actors and writers are
negotiating with the alliance of motion
picture and television producers or
amptp and the amptp represents major
Studio bosses and producers such as Sony
Universal Paramount Walt Disney Studios
Warner Brothers plus major streamers
like Netflix Amazon and Apple tv plus
and the strikers are concerned about a
number of different topics including low
pay residuals streaming and the use of
AI and those topics probably require
their own dedicated video and while
YouTubers aren't generally members of
these unions we definitely know what it
feels like to be screwed over by movie
studios and television producers so if
you'd like to support the unions in
their negotiations you can donate to the
link that's down in the description
including sag Afters emergency financial
assistance program which gives emergency
financial aid to members with great
urgent need and their green envelope
grocery Aid provides grocery assistance
to striking writers and actors and if
you know any striking actors or writers
you can get them groceries directly with
today's sponsor hellofresh absolutely
everyone loves hellofresh and if you
already have a hellofresh subscription
why not get a subscription for one of
these striking writers or actors because
hellofresh is a great way to eat
delicious fresh food while still being
healthy it's a great way to get back
into a diet or just eat great food in
fact hellofresh has a whole variety of
calorie smart carb smart pescetarian and
veggie options you can customize it how
you like too hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than week right now they
have summer favorites from backyard
bratwurst bars to Tangy key lime pie now
I'm a do-it-yourself person and I have
to say I was initially pretty skeptical
about hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook
so I didn't think that I needed the help
but actually I loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that I would
never try on my own and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
my door so I didn't have to do any
shopping the produce actually gets to
you faster than a grocery store so it
arrives at Peak freshness and flavor and
it's also super easy to save time
hellofresh cuts out the meal planning
and prep so the recipes only take 20 to
30 minutes to cook literally less time
to cook than it would normally take to
do the shopping and hella fresh is 25
cheaper than takeout so if you'd like to
try hellofresh go to hellofresh.com and
use the code legaleagle50 at checkout
for 50 off plus free shipping yes you
can actually get 50 off plus free
shipping by clicking on the link that's
on screen or down in the description so
click on the link below and use the code
legal eagle 50 at checkout after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court